good morning
and welcome to another halo 5 stream we
are we're going right into war zone
right now we decided to uh you know rob
you're being useless hurry up
i'm being useless right now this is the
intro this is mike this is tay hey
what's up we're playing halo war zone
right now halo 5. and uh it's kicking
off so let's dive in don't look at me
watch the game
dive in switch there we go oh [ __ ]
so this is kind of
they're everywhere so this is i've never
played this map i've only played warzone
once
uh i'm just lobbing grenades i might i
just hit my own player i think
my sprint isn't working oh no it is
weird yes i know you guys got sometimes
you have to just like
depress it yeah
you know what i did the other day i
gotta do this i'm sorry everyone do it
oh like i did this like clench
protection and i wanted to see what it
was i don't know what a i don't know
what it is protection rod dude that's
what it says all right all right
oh god it's so stupid though two more of
these jokers somewhere
oh now there's three
oh they're down below
oh he got me barely
okay watch this ah
so yeah you're we're trying to capture
this point there are three points and
then they spawn you know there
should be ai around there i think
capture that fortress
there's one defender left i don't even
know where actually we gotta kill that
one last defender right oh there's
another there's another neutral outpost
after this
wow
oh this dude's coming
oh [ __ ] yeah are we all just using ars
and you can well yeah once you get more
points like assists and kills you can't
spawn battle rifles or anything uh
battle rifles with bayonets actually too
there's a lot of stuff
you have to have the right
level and the amount of points gotcha
and you have to have the card for it i
have previously unlocked something okay
but you should have a lot saved up there
for the amount of arena we were playing
all right there we go
you know what i'm curious to know is if
there's a cap on how many cards you can
have at once
i know because you could sell them like
i had a bunch of mongi's that i didn't
want guys uh
to the left
have you guys seen any uh ai yet no
no
i'm actually a little surprised this is
this seems to be a very different type
of war zone is this like a like
defend type no well you've there's these
three points that you capture then you
spawn a boss when you do and everything
and there's
but why are these
guys get out of here why are these guys
um oh coming in through the garage
armory is uh the next spot and it's um
outside well you can also yeah also when
you respawn
oh my question is why like when i play
this game you just play ai and then you
all kind of me in the middle this seems
to be like
we are storming the bases and they're
and they're trying to basically slow us
down yeah i don't know i think i've
never seen the other team so
i was only impressed
i was under the impression that there
would be ai defending the bases as well
in addition to human players oh yeah no
they're marines now we're shooting
marines in here
oh [ __ ]
and then once the three outposts are
taken
on top that you can spawn a boss and
that's like a game-changing amount of
points
yeah we gotta get to the enemy core or
something
looks like we all have three energy
points right now to spend
all right bad screw this door going up
give me that assassinate oh
oh you can get saved from an assassinate
i did not always oh oh yeah yeah yeah
some guy shoulder tackled me i didn't
know that you assassinate uh animation i
have is like a pile driver then i just
stab them nice
that's hot
oh man
this is halo baby
i gotta try to get up top
okay so
i guess i can pick
these are cards that i've had before i'm
gonna go with the ghost
oh we're leveling pretty fast okay we're
getting the armory right now oh there's
a dude just smart and smash someone
there's another guy coming in too let's
try this let's try this out oh you got a
ship
yeah so i i
so i have cards right like this it's the
new rec system you get to a level and
you're live oh my god a lot of guys
coming in don't worry rob's coming in on
a ship i'm going to follow him i
wouldn't the ghost i i guarantee you oh
i got four is there anything else i can
unlock i feel like you're gonna
cause mayhem probably so also there are
power-ups power weapons oh i need a
shotgun should i use that oh no this is
oh i got a fuel rod cannon ah he died
before someone killed him before i'll go
railgun oh someone killed me here we go
someone's right
rob in there watch out rob you're not up
uh okay sweet here we go
so yeah not a lot of ai we must just
kill them all already
damn okay let's do some uh well they
have my ghost
so that went well
i guess that would be the the argument
of that's like come on we're almost
there yeah we got it proceed all right
destroy there's the enemy core we gotta
destroy it
oh
[ __ ]
all right looks like so i have a speed
power-up now on like
you feel pretty like titanfall oh crap
those are your ghosts yeah there's your
ghost ah damn i just lost my railgun
nate nate nate
kill the guy in the ghost rob
get your ship back
my car
i feel like he oh they got two they got
two of them now oh you probably got one
so what's the plan here we gotta destroy
oh we got we got a ghost over there too
though doing work
am i wrong in saying this feels like a
kind of like a uh
like more of a like as far as our team
goes like a defensive mode uh we're
taking points right now yeah we we are
the only one taking their defending i
believe so yes and i i don't know if it
reverses or just random i bet it's a
round-based thing right like
yeah so we can go for the core now
obviously but i think i forget how to
spawn bosses fuel rod and because i
don't see a boss
and we're only playing with we're
playing with a thousand points or just
until we destroy the core
yeah buy that thing from that wreck
machine and die
dude what are you doing
turn around me no this ram wasn't like
was
i was running away from him
uh okay i have three points
you just did you just give up and just
start running away from that well yeah
he had to drop me there's no i was not
going to beat him i was trying to get
around a corner
pick my battles
this is ugly we're gonna be here forever
we gotta find a way in
well it's because they keep spawning
ghosts
we got over here i have four oh hey
what's up i should probably go spend
those somewhere
oh what is going on oh [ __ ] they have a
wraith
do they really oh that's right they do
they have a wraith all right let's see
can we get anything yet uh see if i can
i don't have rocket launcher i got a
fuel rod cannon we'll use that sounds
like a good idea right
random vehicles let's try it can i pour
it i got a card that's a random vehicle
oh wait this guy's got a warrant hey hey
hey come here i will all right never
mind oh
where'd you get that oh the random card
it's a random vehicle all right
so these bosses takes one to no one
can i uh get in your wreath
yeah oh dude someone's got smart
genuine pleasure where are you i'm
trying to find you
i'm at our base like our oh you're all
the way back way back yeah i'll come
back i'm coming up i'll come pick you up
see you in like
soon five
get a marine kill oh no you're all the
way i got a few marine kills
i'm coming i'm coming
oh they're just uh oh there you are how
do i get on oh you can get on oh yeah i
got that plasma cannon
protect me eric
i'll kill the small guys you can it goes
way in there oh [ __ ]
dude how do i not kill our teammates
there's one guy in front of mike okay
i'm not in there no you were uh outside
we're right behind you in the raid oh
we're falling
oh this is awkward rob
this is a little awkward sorry oh [ __ ]
dude how do i get back up uh this oh
this way
uh all the way back
all the way back oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah i got a ground pound kill that felt
really good
artillery
i don't even know where they're at
can we go destroy it can we fit in this
thing
oh yeah don't you get out yet oh i'm not
so this guy right here oh should we get
out though watch this
boom baby oh i didn't even see that guy
i was looking at the core i almost got
five energy points all right screw this
deeper let's get deeper oh watch this
are you guys in the base right now oh
yeah we're in it oh no he's not done
i got him though he did i just want you
to know i got him but we thank you he
died a [ __ ] hopefully i'm glad you got
him yeah i'm going to use another level
what energy level you guys oh wow so i i
even though i have
have one card of many cards i got a wart
hog you want to come in
oh really
yeah sniper i do i don't want to come
away i'll do a random weapon
i'm a terrible driver though i'll tell
you that right now we're all terrible
see what i got oh
okay binary rifle uh
did you guys hit the core at all it
looks like was that you uh no we never
got in because the ship i guess you
can't
at least we didn't see an entry point
too
i have no one on my turrets dude i need
you i need you
oh i see you don't go in there that's
because
dude almost right there you're always
shooting me there's a ghost on your six
minutes i know watch out bro you think
i'm trying to get out of here
oh i don't want that god
i just wanted eric don't ever do that
again man all right
ooh what do you got there i got a shoddy
yeah all right sweet binary rifle's
great so we have 32 seconds to kill the
core so we're basically going to fail
really yeah all right let's do it
i just realized that
i'm going anywhere but we i think we get
like a point contribution oh my god
there are so many people in that room
how are you supposed to get in there i
think you're supposed to nadespan i
guess i don't know oh that's so someone
oh someone got the ghost now
dude there's no way 30 kills holy snap
who does uh our top guy
uh sing at 12 spartan kills yeah i have
like nine
um
yeah we lost great
so it's a weird one all right let's
let's cut the stream we're done
oh great this is all that's leaving or
wait what's going on yeah it's just us
saying we failed
you see that butt
that's a hot butt
you think they put armor on it you think
you think you'd have armor on your butt
but
but
no
all right uh
okay so cool great stay in this lobby
got an intermission in the lobby yeah
i'm gonna open a rep pack how about that
oh yeah you guys open these already so i
can show them records it's really just
fun it's it's fun stuff opening package
josh cut to eric
thank you all right here we go
give me that confetti
why is it pain oh so what'd you get long
shot ar look at all those ghosts long
shots ultra certification so what is the
case what does that freaking mean wait
sorry what
what does ultra certification go ghost
ultra that's just like a level of ghost
that's a better ghost
certificate certification lets you use
it in warzone like did you notice a lot
of them were blacked out when you tried
calling in weapons that lets you use
that vehicle and also increases the
chance of getting more of those cards in
future packs and some of these are
permanent so that armor is permanent
so is
yeah the white ones are one-time uses
the black are permanent
dude look at that you got a long shot
assault rifle that was tight yeah it's
like
so that's that's what's really
interesting to me oh [ __ ] scatter shot
and rocket launcher i do not have rocket
launcher all these weapons
they have mods oh look at that nice
visor that's for your that's for your
advisor i'm gonna open this i'm gonna
buy a silver pack right now
uh so random weapon is cool that's
always fun you know rolled the dice oh
[ __ ] uh put a boost on if you have one
really quick well we got some guys
talking
yeah we can meet them once we get in no
uh yeah so you can use those boosts
before maps the those also come in the
packs and then it's uh you if you get
1250 points you could spend it on a
bronze pack 5 000 for a silver and 10
000 for gold obviously the more you
spend the more like you are to get ultra
rare wait for gold though right yeah i i
was curious what bronze would get me i
actually got an ultra rare and a bronze
i just got lucky though so are we
defending now or
i mean that would be the same thing
but you played a different map earlier
right yeah i did there were i was on a
different map i feel like i've so far
i've seen three
now uh
oh [ __ ]
it's just grenade spam city
you know it's a fun city
sounds like a rolling stone song [ __ ]
there sorry
nice get out of here dude
oh watch out you guys are getting
flanked from outside on the right see
i'm just curious how to call it where
you get how you spawn in a box oh what a
piece of [ __ ]
what did you say mike i'm curious how
you spawn those ai bosses because i know
they're worth a lot of points dude i
don't think
there is a point system it said no there
is but i i think this is a different
type of award watch out from the right
they can come from the outside because
yeah remember did you see before the map
it said first a thousand wins
look there's three right here or if we
destroy their core right
it's just we haven't been doing that
enough time behind you over here
uh yeah marine kills are easy but they
obviously give you way less energy oh
i just got ground pounded probably
better off going pretty hard or not
[ __ ] dude yes you see how they're
swarming out there yeah
so if you get to five energy and spend
them
you still regain it it's just you have
to wait for that to recharge
dude these guys are
kicking our ass
all right
wow they are they're pushing us back
they're pushing us way back
spawn all right jeez
let's uh you have a warthog by any
chance or anything no dude we gotta get
[ __ ] at this level oh [ __ ] actually
hog right now if you want if you yeah
because that would help where are you
uh i can get a mongoose that's it
it'll help us get there but it's not far
enough away really
well
man they're just like like they're just
in groups we gotta team up oh wait i'm
next to the fortress right now like just
oh [ __ ]
nice eric
there it is oh
oh no no
that looks good i know it looked
promising then i failed hard
if your secondary wasn't
empty you would have been fine
no i actually
bungled that and just switched out of it
even though my second nearest one that's
my fault
did that ball has an overshield
15 grenade [ __ ] dude i'm not doing
anything right
okay we're moving up a little bit
all right does anyone want to bust in
with a warthog sure try it out
all right
oh you got a warhog yeah
this is going to be
this is going to be a uh nade central oh
what's up dude
spraying over a guy
we have 237 to capture this sucker all
right i need i need a turret [ __ ]
double melee bill
great damn it
happened
nothing josh cut away
josh
cut away please
josh cut away please i don't you're
still on the shot
please cut away josh
josh cut away
damn it
it's so good this sucks
oh this
guy could go for spartan smash spawn
smash
bam
oh i didn't kill him damn it
oh my god that is not going well oh i
have more
i gotta ditch this warthog this is so
embarrassing random power weapon we'll
go for it
see what i got
all right go for the rail gun
yeah i feel like i just might always do
the random weapon
where the
i hell i am seriously
an idiot
what is this guy doing over here
oh no but we're definitely not capturing
nothing nope at this rate
all right whoa what
dude i spawn and he killed me
yeah you're damn right we're running
outside
ugh
so you know what's interesting too is
like
like this mode is fascinating to me
because i still know how it really works
but i feel like if the team you're
against
is crushing it
going to level up faster than you is
that right
meaning they're going to yeah they're
going to get actually better
more experienced
yeah
if you have momentum you can keep
unlocking power weapons you get crushed
you get crushed
there's not
there's like not a chance for you in the
end well that's where random weapon
stuff comes into play oh my god there we
go on the right there's a spartan charge
kill
oh he's got a sword this is what i'm
talking
about this damn talking about
like
about a carbine because seven seconds is
you know plenty of time to crush
that sword guy bring it oh
okay let's get guys
good game guys no it wasn't that was not
a good one
who said
some guy
maybe he was on the other team good game
guys we crashed them yeah it seems like
one of those things where like at least
in in this this specific map it's like
if your team's not good at like killing
people and slaying people five kills i'm
like pushing up i got ten
um i got five it kind of becomes like a
problem you know because then
everyone's kind of respawning at a
different time and they just get they
gain so much map presence you know what
i mean
and they have high ground and stuff like
that it's just kind of dude high ground
right like they pushed us back and then
that was it ah
yeah
that was brutal yeah all right we'll see
what we got here
so this is my guy you get tons of
uh customization option 175 so pick guns
right now
how do i do can we mute these dudes in
the lobby i don't think how do you um
okay okay okay
uh yeah where did you go to your sport
oh is that sparkling he's not on right
now so you push um
but tell him i'll invite him you know i
do and then you go to um i think we're
getting musicians right
let's see here
open pack so i have two packs let's open
in another 1300 you'll have enough for
a gold pack
nice wow okay so remind me again what
saw certification certification when
you're trying to call in rex during the
mass you see that like only a few were
available the other ones you have to
unlock with certification so that just
lets you call in saws now the white ones
though
are your one time use
oh one time so that one just unlocked
saws those white ones are you actually
have to play that card and you burn
through it to call them in later
certification just gives you lets you
get those in the future you get it at
the after the wreck level right like
comment at a certain rec level can i
burn the other ones earlier than i can
with the certification right
um certification just unlocks it like a
permanent like so you have access to it
but the one-time use like you still need
one-time use once to actually call it in
say you have certification but know
you use all your one-time uses
then it won't matter because you can't
call them in those are like a map again
no this is different i think we're
playing against ai i think we're
defending now now there were a.i have
you not seen any marines i've been
killing a few marines not at all they're
not a lot they're more toward the base
eliminated attackers so we're defending
now oh no this is ai no dude this is i
think this is different this is
different this is the one i was thinking
of there's ai defending the base let's
see we have marines
where's the core this is this is the war
zone i want to play right
have those so this is just
who
uh two left somewhere
well i wonder what the enemy team is
doing now i'm assuming the same thing
right
yeah so this one is coming from i think
i think
incoming prometheans all right oh so
then now the those things in the middle
are neutral so we can push up and grab
that yeah
we keep pushing for sure
they're more ai here though that's fine
clear them out
play some pve guys
good call
yeah pick up their grenades too
um
all right so we are here
and then do we defend this later from
the other team well it's captured you
keep pushing right so there's there's
two ways you can win this game as far as
i know like you push oh there's the boss
you see that one thousand one thousand
points to win wait where's oh commando
yeah we definitely need a team of three
to do come in okay so this is the
neutral where you guys at this
i'm right behind i'm near i'm right
behind tay where are you at there's a
there's a manned cannon right outside
the four turn to your left we're to your
left i think we're gonna start running
into other are you guys human players
yeah we're gonna start running at other
players now
this is so clustered going around on the
right i'm going i'm following you
oh they're all [ __ ] here yep there's
uh blue teams here push back don't yeah
don't rush it don't rush it
oh [ __ ] they're behind us
what was that
oh who's that guy oh there's a guy
hugging there right there [ __ ]
him
so where's that boss he's not on the map
anymore
they might have killed him or no that he
wouldn't die
i think blue did kill him look how many
points they have damn dude like a
hundred points how come how come they
spawned it sooner than us
that's my question they don't they don't
spawn it no no the boss is anybody's
kill they just killed him before and
they got a hundred points that's why
they're crushing him closer to their
side though you know he was he was in
the middle i think they were pretty far
away they were we were
um so they're they just took the
fortress you gotta just like rush these
things oh here we go
oh [ __ ] there's a ghost here yeah there
is
oh i think i had a good tornado bobbing
grenades at him yeah oh he's he's almost
done we could
let's go in all right there's guys here
all right that ghost is close there we
go the ghost is done i kind of wish
there was like a battlefield or like
battlefront thing where it's all right
you guys but
uh he's almost dead there you go nice
oh so did we capture this place they did
we're red see now we can capture from
them
so wait is this this is the base that we
were just storming right yeah and they
captured it but we can take it from them
oh it's currently not ours it's no it's
no it's not we're ready right rob right
in front of you yeah i see him oh oh
okay
oh it's ryan noob dude could have saved
your life all right
i'm assuming that's the lanyard so where
uh we have to basically what with the
clear the the base of their creep and
that and that's kind of it right are
they trying to take no like we have to
they have to take it from their humans
now
they can take our armor yeah they're
they are crushing us [ __ ] a dude like
they got a lot of shotgun they got a lot
of points for that uh taking that baits
too
uh
yeah the armory we need to defend that
now
yeah they're about they just took the
armory oh boss boss behind guys or no
that's our core
yeah they took the armory
i just saw the yellow they're saying
they're basically just saying like uh
you guys are gonna lose your [ __ ] no we
just gotta defend
our base
she's a guy
uh so yeah we're taking this back
oh my god dude there's so many blue guys
outside i get it
damn it
you know
we're learning
we're learning everything there's a ship
oh that's ours
oh right okay actually i'm going to get
up
rocket launcher not a chance
in hell
let's see hopefully i got something that
can take out a wraith energy sword not
helpful
we got a bunch of marines back here at
the uh
core because
there's not a [ __ ] goddamn chance now
we're gonna
maybe we should just stay back and not
even grab the armory and then regroup
[ __ ] dude
where the hell did that dude oh jeez
yeah we know
oh
no power weapon i can get is gonna help
us
[ __ ] camo you kidding me
the camo is very good in this game yeah
it's really hard to see
[ __ ]
i thought they got another ghost
oh he had one too
um see i got around the ghost now
going to the armory right now
oh is that there's oh yeah there's a
boss let's go for him
give us some paw they're going for him
too kill those dudes attacking the boss
where is it oh i see
well we got a ghost over there at least
is it a warden damn it they just killed
him look how many points they just got
25 points for that well he wasn't it was
a knight
he was a knight
nice sword kill there um got a rail gun
too this is not the best weapon combo
but uh so we take the armor in oh [ __ ]
we can probably take the army right now
i don't think there are a lot of
well it doesn't
oops it doesn't hurt to kind of push
that
uh is there another boss right back
there
uh crazy all right we're taking the
armor if we can defend it from these
dudes coming in
oh there's totally promethean back here
oh there's an elite back damn it i
missed i missed
[ __ ]
enemies
no idea the points that gave us though
what capturing it i killed an elite oh
uh 20 i don't know depends on the boss i
think it gave us 25 it looked like
so what do you get for a kill how many
points does your team get
i don't
know uh one i think
yeah one the boss is like 25.
her ai might be one humans might be more
i haven't been paying attention oh my
god there's a sniper on top of the
armory he's a he's a real [ __ ] pretty
sure it's just one point
oh i almost saved that dude from
dude i am playing like
crap
i just need to go home and rethink my
life
points
there's power weapons all right what
should i try here
fuel rod
yeah
fuel rod i'm gonna light you guys want
to grab a warthog with me actually i'm
gonna spawn a random like
this base up but if i spawn and die
immediately with a fuel rod why can't i
spawn right now because oh there's a
boss captain warsaw i'm pressing x
oh okay i got a ghost
that was hoping for but
something eliminated oh they killed him
150 points dude 150 yeah
really an elite guy but what i don't
know but he was like a boss guy goddamn
teammate i'm a [ __ ] idiot
oh they have a banshee in the air what i
don't understand is why they're all of
the the mobs have been spawning on their
side and not our side
well so that's the issue is that no it's
so far back yeah we're just far back
they're spawning they're spawning in
places
we simply can't get to because they're
just yeah they just have close response
annihilating our spawn okay
okay so the ghost is actually pretty
wrecking people
oh there's another ghost i'm gonna go
for the ghost battle
[ __ ]
uh
i'm playing so amazingly
oh geez they have a banshee have you
seen that
yeah oh yeah they have a banshee
uh so mike why oh because it's level
three okay so that's why i can't
i can't take these uh dammit
right so you're at level four if you
wait long enough you'll have all four
again if they recharge um
oh behind you
see that times ten tells you how many
more of those cards you have
where was that like on the bottom yeah
the the
big colored
number at the top is the energy you need
the times 10 is like how many in the
pack you how many of that card you have
left to use
in general like collectively not this
just this game okay so let's
get crushed
this guy's name is just sauron oh eric
with the tydra nice dude a random weapon
got lucky i guess oh really you can lock
on with this one right
that's right
oh yeah oh yeah
i was gonna die
yeah take him out
oh he's a he's a quick one uh yeah you
have to launch a few of those and it's
not the most part they're not the most
yeah yeah you want to definitely want to
unload you get one lock and you fire as
many as you can
here we go here we go oh [ __ ] but like
you're gonna get them i can feel it dude
i'm trying to there's one thing i'm
trying to hijack that you're going to
take that [ __ ] down
oh i'm out of football it's great
everyone shoot him
we need to kill him that's the one win
we'll have this game everyone shoot him
shoot
him gone
there's guys coming up our left side i
mean
right side so
don't focus too much on the left
he flew away he's all the way like back
home he'll be back he'll be back
there he is there's our guy everyone
shoot him
am i really out of bullets already oh
god damn it
this guy wants to go let's do it let's
do it let's do it i want you to do that
is that banshee still
oh he was in the back somewhere
yeah he's a real [ __ ] he's somewhere
ah damn it they stuck out here we go
here we go here we go
nice dude
that looks like that oh he got it though
he got oh he told oh the kill i got an
assist on it he didn't get the ground
and pound killer
it looked really good oh yeah okay i'm
level five so i'm i don't want to wait
for that
i don't know i also don't want to waste
all these cards if we're not gonna win
so chris oh you're capturing it for
footage right so
yeah
but i get i get it though i get it i get
it i was like but i wanna
dude they are they're they're pushing on
us really bad
well i got a perfect kill i'm cutting
half pretty bad
oops
something
something went wrong there so they're
close to winning
yeah
yeah we're far if we could somehow
miraculously push back and all they need
to do is get all they need to do is uh
just kill die if everyone died on their
team they could probably win
[ __ ]
dude i want a freaking tank
yep
what did they just do to get that last
oh my god i think they just i think they
just killed a boss
looking good guys
we're learning eric
so are they i think
oh i got some kind of you got three
packs
me yeah
i know
i'm really close to a gold you could
probably buy a gold pack right now if
you wanted to i could
okay i don't need all these mines i'm
gonna sell that all right let's open
these packs what did i get here
i got speed boost a saw a mongoose who
cares about a mongoose
i got helpful for transportation if you
just want to get somewhere fast
yeah that's true
i almost have enough for
a gold pack
stop giving me mongoose
man you could do this all day you could
open these packs all day look at me dude
i've gotten literally like like eight
mongooses
so you can sell these right yeah so
so
ooh
that's a trap so
new playlists
so holy god there are a lot of armors
there's builder
dude look at taylor look at tay his
screen
that's what you know i found one yeah so
take this oh they're rare
nice dude so yeah there are uh 175
different types of armor not counting
the helmets not the 175 helmets yeah
that's 175 helmets look at that i don't
think i got a helmet yet
kind of like i got a rare helmet going
right here
this is how they're going to get you oh
wait wait no never mind exactly this is
definitely how they're gonna get you
gotta get them all
um
tay do you did you mean to put the
filter that shows all of them on
because you could press wide i just only
have the ones
yeah i know but it's just because you
guys were talking about how many times
put a boost on if you have them how do i
do that dude what the hell is that [ __ ]
you get them in packs and these just
like increase your experience that you
get after finish wars on game and you
get plus 200 in addition to what you've
gained anyways
requisition rates
pick seven this is uh one of the new
ones i have not played but i've seen so
excited to play this
great so this is just like the one we
just did yeah raid there we go i don't
know or no redone yeah
all right
look better let's start forming up yeah
that's that's how they were kicking ass
is that is it you can you will never win
a 1v4 situation like are you sure it's
just because you're not have better
names eric that's what i'm going for
that's what i'm going with all right all
right don't you i agree let me justify
it don't you dare initiate there's three
of us the storm let's store mom
yeah this looks like um valhalla cut
their arm off and shut up
so no time limits it's like i was saying
earlier though it would be nice for me
to be able to
squat up on you
as if like since we're playing together
yeah like when you're on the battlefield
for me to be able to get to you instead
of just respawning in the back and like
running to you and i'm like where are
you exactly i don't know where you are
no there's nothing wrong with waiting
like we just if we wait and warm up
let's kill some jackal this is like
silent cartographer right here anybody
want to join 100
which is uh coincidentally my favorite
mission in the first game maybe of all
halo every halo
on the left
yeah got him got him got him
oh and he oh i thought that was a
carbine damn it's so fun to do that to
storm um all right where are we
so fun i love wait [ __ ] hold on we got
to kill the last
um
oh god
what what
i just got booted that well that that
means you will too right you could
probably still join see if you can just
try yes
all right um try to join on us
damn it we have loadouts here and i just
i want the dmr that's that's my gun and
i have to wait until i unlock it like
this
oh there's a
boss guy a hunter blade guy should we
chase him uh where do you have vps i'm
in the armory right now okay east armory
someone's talking yeah east armory
um he's worth 25 vps
oh there's a couple guys there's only
25. the fire team and then and then try
to join you should be able to still join
where am i going i'm going to inspire i
don't know where i'm going i'm going to
inspire to try to get these uh hunter
elders okay
dude i don't know how to get the hell
out of here
oh there's some red team here though
this is this is
josh don't watch me i'm lost get out of
here
uh josh cut away i died too though josh
cut away don't watch me
can somebody can you try inviting me
josh cut away watch someone else
everyone else is dead okay fine watch me
we'll run
how do i invite you from here though i
don't know if you can
you might have to go to the dashboard
i'll get into my own game i'll see if i
can
maybe we can get a few maps going on
should we just leave
no don't
yes i'm looking for my own war zone
match because i got booted for whatever
oh they're a few bosses i'm heading out
to the hunters all right elders dude
this map is [ __ ] sick what is your um
like
four letter
tag called i don't even know dude dude
you need to know these things eric i'm
not as pro at making
i need to name it babe i need to see you
on the field babe all right uh it's it's
oxyn i think
oh they have health bars that's super
weird why wouldn't they whoa
because hunters you just never halo you
never see health bars with boss you just
kill them
dude this map is tight take another one
down all right we got both guys oh
there's a zealot down here
or no it's a hundred clicks away
teammates eliminated 100
i'm gonna try to go through it eric i
love the lingo you're throwing it
clicks didn't you guys use that lingo
earlier i didn't say it i think mike did
because mike would i never said clicks
and i wouldn't
then here clicks
bozos you guys are actually doing well
but i'm not in this game dude
we're doing it check out what i'm doing
this is fun
are you joining me are you joining like
no it won't let me mistake i asked i was
going to see if you guys could try
inviting me but i don't think that would
work either
you want me to try
yeah just try to go to like the friends
on the dashboard and invite me
oh watch this this is it yeah stay on
robs for now
whoa i think you just pressed pre-order
halo 5.
just back out
like you're on halo 5 and you just
pre-ordered it
no this halo 5 is very good i'm gonna
get another one
maybe the second one halo 5 will be
better
this is so slow send party and game
invites
amazing party but okay level three no
all right
just game game invite
let's see if it'll i just sent it
thank you did you try joining from that
dashboard yeah
all right i'm back oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
grab a
battle rifle dude i'm so good at this
game
all right got a battle rifle let's go
did they kill that other guy the dude on
the that was on the left
like the ai guy
player left uh mike so maybe someone you
can join yeah i'm trying to also marcus
phoenix is on the other team oh man
so yeah these are just
set up for pre-release servers and we've
been playing with the same people for a
few days behind your hot rob it's just
waiting to join a match in progress
i don't know they're behind me
all right
all right let's take this armory tape
pushing really conservative all right
which way you going
um
oh watch out above you
i gotta keep moving hopefully this
connects soon
i'm trying to catch up to you
they're on the top back grenade
nice nice shot rob all right
let's do this all right okay i think
we're looking pretty going inside with
you oh there's a guy inside
it's so hard to not shoot you in the
back he's dead yep someone else got him
there's one more on top we're claiming
we're taking this right now already
yeah we got a guy in a ghost up here in
a ghost up on top yeah
dude what a what a crazy [ __ ]
oh my god teammate of the year got a
ghost on top
breaking breaking rules
oh is there a guy i'm gonna do groundhog
come on let me do it
that rock on the way all right we gotta
go to the enemy
rob that was really tight what's going
on enemy core last part no i guess oh
there's a boss in the back here oh dude
dude some guy's fighting with the ghost
oh let's do it is it is it what's this
the ghost marauder
oh look at this beast
go hijack that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's kicking
my ass
still waiting to join a match
dude it's just fun i'm having fun sick
mike
let's hook it in
dude this is one of the best dude this
menu screen is made oh pretty amazing
though oh there you go oh i can't can't
do this dude i can't that's kind of
that's kind of weak yeah can't
hijack him all right he's dead
that got you 25 points
we're going to win this
uh oh there you are etay i'm right
behind you dude all right god you look
so good um that's my butt
no we can't we can't but he can't shoot
us either look how dumb he looks like
dummy looks do i kill him i bet he's
gonna come out of there yeah he will
do that i just went into a campaign for
a second and backed out was crazy you
guys should have seen it
like an adventure idiot
where are you oh [ __ ] where are you
come to me all right i will come to you
oh he's gonna come out again watch us
okay
dude if in destiny i would be slash
dancing right now
oh but he can go back inside yeah
let's leave he'll he'll follow us he's
got nothing else to do all right where
are we going though dude i think we go
back around to the left oh did you go
that way why don't we go that way okay
i'll come back to you i don't really oh
there's a boss over there oh i'll follow
you wait yeah i'm on the riverside
over here
yeah yeah
all right let's do this it's a yellow
yellow dude this is one of the coolest
maps it's pretty far though now we'll
get to them
also we've got like 250 meters so i'm
safe about this okay sure i'm right
behind you guys oh nice
yeah
like no i'm trying to get into a match
these requisitions are sweet though you
guys check this out
tank master rock oh dude oh he's into my
bro
he's well there's a reason why they call
him the tank master
turns out he's in a tank
is there a requisition thing over here
look at this [ __ ] dude get over here
gloria okay
you can kill this
get the turret there you go well that
was easy oh i got killed by him oh dude
i got no more ammo can i take your ammo
yeah i have no ammo i have no battle
rifle ammo oh my god i got nothing
i have i have a pistol
go spartan smash him all right let's try
this out
big red
big red is losing it
all right
oh my god that actually didn't uh
it looked like it did oh that was funny
rob's spawning oh look at you
eric i will get in that turn turret and
should i wait in the base so i don't get
shot in a heartbeat i will be in there
with you
uh other side i think uh go that way
where i'm on the opposite side
yeah
uh
you know just just like that time i was
picked last for dodgeball oh
eric
get in
i'm a terrible driver but get in take
smashing all right let's do it let's go
find that tank master
it could be only one there can be only
one oh look at dude look at his health
we like hey where are you guys [ __ ]
dude he's got it so these are boosts
uh
so you know that like
i don't know you'll figure it out get
there oh [ __ ] someone else is attacking
him oh someone just took him out no
they got 150 they almost caught up with
that shut up because of that well
they're all here now let's let's check
them out oh my god
yeah he must have been oh he's got a
rocket launcher oh that okay look so i
have i only have a certain amount of
range so be sure that whenever there's
an enemy you're facing it you're facing
yeah like right there yeah like this is
like that guy's dead i think there's a
guy i think there's a guy behind us
you're killing it right now really yeah
this one was shooting us
i don't see him yeah we killed him i
don't know we're good
where are we going where do you want to
go i don't know where you want to go is
there like a 7-eleven around here this
is so
i'm i'm looking forward to helping out
right so let's go to the east armory i
think that's where we should go
you got it this is a little dangerous oh
you said you guys must have just called
the boss or took taking the new armor
it's so elaborate i love it oh there's
there's guys you just got a bunch of
points for something
for being hot oh they we gotta take that
out
yeah
all right
oh that's just way over get out of here
get out of here pull back pull back
really yeah yeah this is where you pull
back and you let your your shields
recharge because they're gonna keep
hitting us okay you got it
yeah also you kind of want a lot of
range of the wraith because they can
yeah they can hijack this is like
artillery right here
oh [ __ ] oh we're good no who's shooting
this banshee banshee oh banji oh there's
a banshee right oh what they just
crashed the belt ball and he's got he's
got a posse dude there's is that is that
ai oh yeah yeah no that's a yeah it is
oh god
you are defenseless up close i am in the
mud
dead oh
i think you hit them good run good run
oh geez i'll be right there dude
shut up eric you did great shut up dude
all right let me take a ghost
confirmed
all right
oh there's another is that the boss guys
incoming prometheans
oh someone's got a scorpion you can jump
can you jump on the side or do you get
in that turret i can't
why doesn't there's no space
yeah there is
i'm on top no get
in yeah
yes
follow me i'll lead the way i'll be like
the scout oh god oh that's our 100
captain
captain hestro 405
oh that scorpion should hit that banshee
oh i'm reigning oh yeah nice that's
going to be like 25 points
there's 25. now get the legendary dude
he'll be 150. all right yeah we gotta go
get cat the captain let's go get the cap
oh banshee to the left i think
right you're right good call
a lot of enemy humans near that armory
oh oh dude you're getting you gotta pull
back oh god you're getting hijacked i
killed a banshee though
how'd it go
i killed two banshees
and then i don't know something blew us
up
oh ah see ya
oh he's on a phaeton boss is still over
there
dude that
phaeton boss behind you is
asking for it
i'm not gonna go for him i don't i don't
have the power to take on
yes i got to hydro launcher all right
we got one bullet left though
captain hestrol what are you doing out
there
we need to get um some requisition
weapons to kill that guy
we can't let him have that because
that's like another 150 points yeah or
we need like a vehicle all right you
want to swarm it let's team up
you want to do it sure i'm shooting it
from the ground it's not going to do
anything oh yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] oh you traded
no you didn't never mind yeah you did
is that even doing anything i don't
think it is
all right do i have any lock oh dude
spartan laser oh it's on dude go get
that fast right the captain captain
hestra testro it's on he's half-life
right now
oh [ __ ] so far away hopefully that's
your team hitting him
i'm coming
oh god [ __ ]
oh god that's this is where a mongoose
would be helpful
yeah but unfortunately it seems like you
can't you know you can't get it right
right it would be helpful if you can
kind of communicate with the team kill
him so
yeah he's
give me to um
whatever they
the soldier have
uh damn it oh you guys got him try it
time to go band
he's gone yeah how was your team damn i
really wanted that kill
yeah
i got a banshee though okay press that
why tight you got it
uh between like a secondary like you
know oh i'm gonna fly like that guy holy
crap
oh [ __ ] look at that though man
yeah so we're pretty much playing
warzone arena which is just classic
multiplayer uh all weekend
um
monday is the embargo for the review but
we're not gonna put up a full review on
monday because um as is off can happen
with these games the servers might not
be the best so
we're going to have a review ready but
the earliest we're going to publish a
review oh sorry to interrupt no no
that's fine that was a nice shot that
was really good i'm not good with the
spartan laser no dude it's tough you
have to i have a friend who's just has
that charge down so when he rounds a
corner it's ready to fire well what it
really is is like you charge up
and right before
right before the deed happens
you like i have to have that last minute
like
adjustment you know what i mean it's
like it's like a last second
like fix the crosshair
just before i don't know the railgun's
similar but it's got a shorter charge
it's not as powerful but it's a little
easier to use yeah um they're kind of
similar though but yeah you have to if
it's a vehicle it's a little easier if
you're trying to get on another fuel rod
um
no no it's just recharges unlimited dude
infinite ammo eric so yeah the earliest
we'll have a review up is release day
the 27th which is tuesday um
you just want to make sure the servers
we don't want to publish a review not
knowing how the public servers are going
to be because these are just pre-release
servers that we're playing on right now
with warzone arena
so we'll have something up monday for my
thoughts on the campaign whatnot and how
i like the multiplayer with the servers
that we are using now
and then come tuesday we'll hopefully
that's the earliest we'll be able to
publish a review if all goes well
hopefully the servers you know are good
so people can get in and start playing
this because i've been having you know
warzone's pretty interesting warzone is
so interesting and uh and this menu
screen is
super fun uh i don't know if you guys
have been watching what i've been doing
but someone came in and then backed out
it was crazy kind of looks lame don't
kid yourself but this looks fun what you
guys are doing was this uh shooting
people
interaction yeah i guess so
um
yeah so if all goes well tuesday we'll
have a full review up scored and
everything
yeah probably play a little more co-op
campaign with you guys today over the
weekend maybe see what's up we played we
played a lot yesterday co-op is pretty
fun um it's better than single player
i'm doing this though
this is uh
wow yeah this is fun this is good this
is uh this is this is halo right here
this is what
come on
drive are you are you freaking game oh
my god sniper
oh you got a rocket launcher
what oh wait no we're about to win
there's no point i was going to use the
randomness
what if
uh so there's no more boss out right now
they don't have a lot of opportunities
to catch up except for taking the spire
yeah see like that's the kind of
interesting thing right like i don't
know what the comeback mechanic is it's
not impossible they just really need to
group up and take because you guys okay
so if you guys don't complete any more
objectives the only way for you to win
is to get killed 71 more sorry 61 more
kills which could take a while if
they really group up and start if they
take a spire that could spawn a boss
which could taking the outpost i'm not
sure how many points that is that could
spawn a boss which you know give 25 but
it could give 150.
and so it's not impossible but it's very
unlikely at this point
all right it's sniper time
um
dude i love this setting just like yeah
jungle leaves this is great it's just
cartographer strap
uh
not yeah i was gonna say you can zoom in
with the left side
i blew it
shot on you where was he
i don't know
prometheans are warping in
oh there's a legendary boss see if they
go for that let's meet up prometheans
let's meet up dude i want to party a
warden oh [ __ ] yeah let's go check him
out he'll be
huge dude all right oh [ __ ] i'm heading
back to that side i'm dead
you should be in time to spawn i'll
check them out hopefully you get there
how many points you have right now six
saved up not saved up oh no yeah six
where where is it you're level six but
you only have two charges up right now
because you just spent a few on the uh
sniper rifle yeah but they recharged and
you can whoa
oh oh i thought you got that shot that
was good you see the boss
yeah
oh he just he's vaporizing people with
that
stare
oh my god oh there's my man
hey dude
hold still
oh
[ __ ] what he just what did he do he
cyclops you
stare yeah
uh nice nice job i wanted to go
i wanted to see the wardens
i just used an uncommon ghost to get
there
is there a different oh so he's got butt
armor what a the other person not oh
that was a chick
you know the girls always gotta look
better dude
although that was a really cool map
what that dude that's like the coolest
that's the coolest guys got some packs
check them out all right let's check out
these packs you got it i got all right i
can buy a gold pack yeah go for it let's
show them let's show them opening a gold
pack i got a gold pack i got a promotion
award and inside
unlock the wait
smg with the launchers the defender
helmet that's pretty sweet
another ghost ultra yeah so those are
all one time that helmet's pretty
good
oh
ultra rare random vehicle it's pretty
sweet
man guys it's purple those cost uh six
i'm sensing a little sarcasm
well because of purple and destiny would
be a legendary
here we go
and here
okay you have a lot of wreck points you
still have seven thousand i'm gonna wait
for another gold pack i'm not
recommending you spend them i'm just
saying you have a lot i know i know
merely stating anyone got any like
weapon skins because i haven't seen uh
i'm
like click into the gun once you look at
the skins like
that mike by the way no no this is it i
wonder yeah you just need to oh hey we
got we picked up chris though all right
wait wait back can you i can't back out
can you invite me to
i don't i don't know i don't know this
game uh wait what time are we how do i
stop
just back press b i i am pushing
i can never leave the war zone
i don't know
you can't back out either i'm hitting b
i've been spamming
dude all right we're about to deploy
though
um
all right well let's let's quit
in game okay
are we uh how long are we streaming for
i don't know we could do one more war
zone can i yeah can i try to get in
well maybe
oh no yeah put out and then invite me in
because i very much like to uh play this
game
leave game do it just do it i don't know
if jointed jeans over there can hear us
but we just quit that game for this
irish axe guy okay
all right
uh yeah let me join your team now
i'm not in your fire team anymore either
i don't think well let me invite you
guys to invite me hang out
invite
invite
uh-oh
what's happening oh you can join i
joined how come no it's not it didn't
like
i couldn't join just now either oh now i
can i can join mike who are we joining
on here we go jordan rob
i can't join rob i'm sorry okay now try
this is what i said okay i'm with rob so
try joining me you guys could go to go
to me oh you know why because we're not
actual friends on uh xbox live i thought
yeah because and we haven't accepted
each other like i had to wait till okay
so is this all of us we got four sweet
oh so we got is this chris i don't know
if it's someone over there it might be
it's either randy ramsey jake decker or
chris waters yeah
i think we're gonna try one more horizon
yeah so we got uh this is four people in
the fire team we got another uh
game spotter playing no one knows who
but it's it's another game spot guy so
how did you change oh over here
oh yeah that's uh i got tears
that's your service tag what are you
gonna go for don't do hot that's me i
thought that was just how you find me
but don't do hot that's my name
i'm hot b
uh we just lost jointed jeans they just
booted from the lobby and we can't quit
now oh yeah you can uh rob your leader
you can quit yeah let's quit out and try
to get all four
really
you guys got to quit too
so leave fire yeah we came with you
okay we're still afraid yeah okay okay
wait let's uh who is this person we
gotta get joined to jeans again
i think it's that's uh
so they should just probably join they
should join on me
all right then there you go
all right sweet try queue it up now look
at this guy joining jeans level one
here
and chris is home today no it can't be
chris though he it's on the other xbox
check randy in his office there's no
one's in his office
somebody has it or is there a random guy
no no no that's that's definitely randy
james it's definitely someone from
gamespot yeah
but whatever so here we are playing halo
5. uh warzone
hopefully we'll play that last map again
because that was the most fun i've ever
had
ever yeah it looks really fun i was i
had fun watching i really did feeling
we're not going to get in the game
i like the dynamic between you know
running in with trying to get a power
weapon from the wreck thing getting
enough kills to get a wraith to battle
the other rates and getting like a
random weapon and then
having a legendary boss that everybody's
rushing for
so is there anyone past that guy pastor
ray
what do you mean sorry not the rate uh
the the last boss that we saw in the uh
last map what do you mean past him like
are there more bosses
after that yeah they're not it's not a
set in order it's just random like
legendary one
i think yeah he seems like an end game
right like yeah he seemed strong
i mean it makes sense the campaign yeah
that's fair to say i don't know man like
i i feel like it's fairly random because
it seems like a random input like you
could just throw in any type of dude i
like the variety though i don't know if
it's
if it's like preset like you're going to
see the exact same warden every time i
don't know
like you know
i will say though like i've seen this
map played before
and
like those two hunters
that are on the map i've seen that
before like early game like you go and
you and you take out two hunters so i
feel like maybe part of it is systematic
like hunters
but they seem to be already on the map
is what i'm trying to say i feel like
that's that's a given potentially and
then you get
just random dudes who get thrown in i'm
kind of curious too like you know that
one map where we got smashed where like
you kind of run into each other like
right away trying to assault the place
yeah i'm not as fond of that as i am of
like
like that last map where it's like both
sides are like kind of infiltrating
killing some of like prometheans or
whatever you get both of your
headquarters so to speak and then you
start fighting for the rest of the map
yeah i was wondering if that was just a
different type of war zone yeah or if we
joined late in the match
no we started that one member and we
just got creamed in the beginning oh
that was a timer thing and then like
they just
you know eventually slayed us so bad
that like as we were respawning like we
never grouped up or whatever and we just
kept dying yeah one by one see that's
why like i i don't know i like the war
zone where it's like
cut and dry
two sides two bases
that's more
like plausible as like a match like when
it's when it was when it was attacked
defend
dude it seemed so lopsided i don't know
because that was like that was like
crushed dude i was even spawning and
they were killing me
like when that's happening that's not a
very good game yeah i was
hoping for one kill before i died
yeah that got really ugly
and uh so is this matchmaking right now
i'm wondering if yeah because there's
not a ton of people playing warzone
right now i'm wondering if that match
that we just left got booted out of
whoever's joined the jeans was like the
one going on right now
and i don't know that we'd be able to
join four people during it
we could just uh play arena if we don't
get in the next
minute or so
sure
well uh
why don't we just do that now okay
marina we should have more luck
well we are
quite half of the game
what's that we're like half of an arena
game yeah it is
yeah it was fun when we did capture the
flag i think yesterday i didn't play
capture flag there's like swat and stuff
like that but here we go yeah capture
flag was fine i like halo's capture flag
you have to have your own flag at the
base to this is capture the flag
actually all right nice this is the one
this is the map we did too yep
great all right jointed jeans you're not
gonna hear any of our call outs but you
know almost there i don't even want to
hear him speak damn
it's like that all right if they're
listening to the stream
tag is yeah
so yeah you need to we need to have our
flag at our base to score when we return
there so it kind of becomes a matter of
having one and also getting there's
sweet so that defender helmet's pretty
sweet
yeah you like it it's okay all right it
wasn't ultra rare so uh you guys want to
get the group up get the power weapons
go
good call oh they're going for the
sniper right now
oh i love the hover the smartlink cover
it's great
got him
there's two on the left and they got the
sniper oh yep he just hit me with it
didn't kill me but i'm going for it baby
uh yeah i think i can't sprint try to go
oh come on should be a one-hit kill i
got him i got him i got the flag
oh [ __ ] i didn't toss it though the
second time
there's one there get there get there
dude there
[ __ ] i held them up for a little bit
uh they returned it
let's uh watch ours i don't know where
the other two are no no they they're the
sniper on the right side
he's dead
you got the dimmer um all right
there's a sniper on the right i think
the dmr spawns in the base i believe
uh
it does that's where i got it from okay
um i don't
how to join to jeans die that worries me
oh [ __ ]
this is where descoping becomes awesome
because they can't
nice i'm going for the flag do it i'm uh
i'm going i'm going all right our left
side our left side
are left yeah i see it oh i'm right
behind one of them he doesn't see me
though get you covered oh hold on
keep running keep running
behind me
i got you i got you uh yeah get the flag
you guys got it you got it you got it
did i pick it up oh no i got it got it
oh we got two escorting all right i'm
coming back
i'm back i'm back in the bag nice see
this this guy's got the whole [ __ ]
chain
that's you yeah all right run it you
guys are good sweet tight do we have our
flight oh we don't have our flag all
right hey just chill here let's go kill
their flag carrier you got it [ __ ] he's
although he's top middle
oh [ __ ] dude
i killed him i killed him someone just
needs their nice nice nice weight where
is it it's top middle dude right here
who in their base who has that
what uh i have the flag okay i can't
score it though oh okay i thought you
said you killed him yeah i killed him
he's all the way caught the flag oh it's
it's returning as long as we
oh they're not uh they picked up again
i'll go i'm over uh rob are you what are
you i'm gonna try to get our flag back
all right i'm gonna i'll help tay out
nice nice just coming today yeah i'm on
the point already if you can return it
you just gotta stand on it stand next to
it yeah it speeds up
yeah nice job
all right we got a little bit that was
great i got sniper too why am i yelling
because they're excited that's right
here we go do some snipping the sniper
is coming the new sniper's in like 15.
yeah i've got uh
two rounds with it hopefully that's two
kills
don't suck
rob you gonna go for a flag uh yeah
there's a couple guys in here so if we
can get one more point we have some
pretty good cushion to just defend or
you know get that last point like we did
the last time all right i'm going for it
let's party i've got a sniper right
right now he's going down the middle
they won't see it coming
they're on our left side oh there's one
there you snapped him yep uh there's a
guy at our base he's about to take our
flag but we're good he's going on our
he's near uh from our basement
nice nice nice stuff yeah dude i dropped
their sniper too so we're good we're
good there's a guy right here okay hold
on
we're good nice nice job there's two
uh you wanna we got this let's just go
for it right fella okay i got three to
win or want to defend and just wait out
this eight minutes no i just go for it
okay let's get some food uh guys going
for the power weapon on the right is
that rocket i'll hang back and defend i
guess i'll let me know when you get it
he's got rocket he's got
no
i don't know but i have the rocket
launcher now
all right i i got this guy near our base
okay we're good right now whoever uh
joined the genes
here we go about to win gg yeah nice
nice job where are you at so i can shoot
you with this rocket launcher
that was uh jointed jeans finished it
off
that's a hot team right there that's
pretty sweet guy on the left was the
hottest
it's kind of awkward having like a red
uh like
visor when you're on blue team
it's deceiving oh wow 9 kd i gotta we
got to keep this one
that's never happening again yeah that's
pretty cool
that's never happening again man
uh one point two dude we crushed him
let's do that again i had a sniper duel
while you guys were scoring points for
us nice that's cool you know what's
funny i've never ran a flag in halo
before i'll tell you that right now you
just did it earlier oh my god
when i was throwing it i only know to do
that because i watched what were you
doing jumping pressing y and then
grabbing it again
the jump is pretty essential oh yeah
otherwise you'll just go like two feet
in front of you right
you jump through yeah the first time
they showed this map back at like around
e3 i saw them doing i mean it's like a
halo staple to do that but they were
doing it like
jumping and then doing the boost down to
grab it again and then throwing it and
then boosting to get spartan grub out
not the ground pound just the dash and
they would throw it hit the ground dash
grab it jump throw it for sure dash yeah
super efficient yeah oh this is a new uh
oh swag
it's swat with
pistols oh god
like golden gun like gold yeah i know it
takes two hits with a pistol okay battle
royale
the trick is here is to aim for the head
yeah
swat's great battle rifles is really
tense though because it's one burst and
you're dead
uh pistols you know it's usually two oh
that's cool this map got changed i
remember this in beta but it looks a
little bit like it's kind of like a
ship-ish it's like it's like war-torn
it's that's interesting i can't decide
if my is cool or dumb all we get is
pistols oh my god
yeah no radar it's intense all right
left it's uh
i don't even know nice left is right now
yeah
ooh this is fun i love it damn it
there's a guy in the right too on our
right [ __ ] there's no point going
he's uh he's in the middle somewhere
he's up top
oh he's on the mat
got one
there's one oh we're all together now
that's good
damn both collated i'm right to your
right i'm gonna go down there's another
one there's one there's another one
there in front of you whoever that was
spartan smash is one hit kills too and
groundhog so keep those in mind he just
jumped up there's a guy above you damn
it i saw him well i saw him that he
killed me so oh [ __ ] he's about there no
point really
killed one there's another one down that
hallway there's two down got another one
where is this to the right
nice nice good [ __ ]
uh gonna be hiding behind behind
where oh up top yeah
below i got me that's above sober uh
i don't well respawn time around this
one's fast yeah
yeah real fast
there we go damn it got it got one
watch out there's watch damn try to get
vertical
yeah they're they're uh
and
high ground on us so that's the thing
about the smartlink hover you're you get
a good angle on them but they you're not
mine so they have a easier shot in some
ways there's one bad
there we go there's double nice
guys up there it is one uh sorry i
misspoke it is one it's one for the head
yep whoa this guy's lagging out
dude double kill i'm gonna get a spartan
smash just for
ah is there another one below i got one
i traded you should come upstairs and
hang out
oh i just got punched or something
dude i'm loving this mode oh it's great
i i
only have five battle rifles just tense
as [ __ ] because it's just
longer range you can smoke people from
across the map
another one there
you're near me uh they're in that room
behind you yeah okay two of them
i feel like i got one but
[ __ ] one guy's weak on the left
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] they're behind me behind
us yeah
[ __ ] where i can't i don't know where
these twos are
oh yeah dude i'm feeling am i doing it
dude don't be ground-pounded in this
mode come on jerk
there's a dude there's no motion sounds
you can get above people without them
going
oh my god dude i love this
um
wait till you play the br one that was
pretty funny uh oh behind [ __ ]
oh i should have had that shot
nice jointed jeans
i feel like that must be chris ryan
schubert
oh yeah
yellow as well
i don't think randy's there we go
there's one berserk behind behind behind
whoever it right there we go guys dubs
behind below oh this time below
someone was just not
playing maybe their controller was out
or something damn let's not be in that
middle room that middle room sucked
yeah we you always got to hug the side
right yeah because they're yeah they had
multiple vantage points on us
tape got your uh [ __ ] i missed all right
where was he uh the middle the middle
top
got him ah
nice damn it we're still crushing it is
it 50 yeah it's 50. we got three more
over does this goes for
[ __ ] what was your life
your life i think it does there we go
dude
i wanted to ground pound him so bad but
he turned her oh my god i could end on
that yeah
that was good that was so much fun
uh
one more map sure yeah
oh i got a reward i didn't use a boost
at time i keep forgetting to use those
ooh all right i got enough for a gold
kills
you can go to
uh who's that guy
we all had pretty good damn robcat hot
dude that guy is hot i got the two kd
all right so i died a lot though i'm
gonna get a gold pack really fast while
we're waiting nice
see what i get from this
oh there we go wraith
oh and dude recruit i'm loving this
farmer i got a lot of wraiths open my
pack
so you can also buy i got a little bit
of a snack pack you could buy these too
right like it doesn't have to you can
buy wreck points you can buy real money
with real money yeah dude look at this
like we're just playing for what two
hour
hour hour and a half i got so
and you could sell a [ __ ] load of them
you can sell [ __ ] like how much do you
get for like 50 okay depends on i think
it depends on what it is supposedly the
number oh put a boost down
yeah i just did the assist so what do
you do you press a okay and then just
pick one
break out all right so this is
this is elimination
but you also can return like
return the flag to win the round it's
first to five rounds like is it just a
flag for both teams yes it's a neutral
flag but also elimination and
first of five rounds wins and this is
like in a forge map so you only you only
have uh yeah it's elimination like you
said so if you're dead you're dead yep
so kind of be a little more conservative
i guess
or just kill them
oh who's that guy
that's pretty sweet and then they have
this like running start this is weird
yeah
there's also a battle rifle right here
which i'm going to grab if that's okay
do it
i'm one right side oh yeah it's not
coming on the right flag
oh [ __ ] there's i got a hydra oh i'm all
right got one dude we
i got one four two four two we're good
oh yeah
i just pardoned smashed him i want to
kill someone
can i go got him
got him great i did absolutely nothing
got three of those three why are you
throwing in there they all were on the
same side yeah i had a battery i flanked
them with the hydrant i only killed one
guy dude so the flag is why why to kind
of give an objective right it gives an
objection if you're if you have four
people left and you can't find that last
guy and just want to say all right i
mean it's not hard to find him on here
but yeah i guess it makes sense it's i
think it's like yeah the the
disadvantage it can also be a last
resort for the if you're like the last
person these guys are trying to get the
hydra extremely hard
they got it they got the flag
they smoked us that round
well we smoked them the first time i'm
gonna grab the battle rifle right at the
beginning again because i did well with
that
they just got smarter about where to
like separate that's all you want to all
go left all right but the hydraulic
lancers on the right just uh let's all
[ __ ] all right let's go left
the hydra launcher
all right i got the battle rifle let's
go
they're gonna be gonna need them there
they got me with nades last time they're
already pushing up one guy's pushing up
uh he killed me
uh rob there's a dm behind you guys he's
behind you guys i see him
he's coming from our spawn
damn he's spartan smashing
[ __ ] yeah he's
i just realized you're not motion
sensors either
yeah you're good it's you and uh
oh [ __ ] you jointed yeah it's just chris
left or whoever that is
he's gonna have a hard time nice oh one
on one here we go
who is this guy
who is this
devil oh my god he's like no no no no oh
my god that's the wrong way right damn
it you went the wrong way yeah no no no
you take it to there
so he was close then he was close he
should have threw it
he did at the end right he died oh
one guy went left i'm going left oh yeah
at the left
left is where it's at
got one [ __ ] damn it got me with the
from the grave grenade
uh
a brave grenade how did that knock you
nice shot rob thanks um
one more he's got the wall what's going
on here i think he has he had the flag
nice nice job
oh they have one more i thought that was
the last one
who's up top rob
nice job
that was my round that was my round nice
was that all four three
i got a three three i got three i can't
believe that how you doing that was my
round
that was bad
yeah i got one that he needed me
god that's fun
all right going for this
definitely one going mid to left some
peak i'm more of a left guy yeah left is
working out
oh [ __ ] this dude just needs
he loves those nades
oh
someone just
promethean grenaded me
watch out rob one of them might have the
hydra
oh what the hell was that nice good job
oh they don't let you rotate the camera
to call it out either like exactly i was
looking at that tv oh [ __ ] nice good
dash
[ __ ] good try guitar i should have
crouched is this uh is this around how
many rounds is it it's seven i guess
first to four so no it's first of five
oh okay um it's not best of yeah it's
just it keeps going until someone hits
five
which what's the max of that like oh so
does it just keep adding rounds as like
to adjust yeah
uh one went left
watching yeah the students
near there that's a hydro launcher in
front of you though okay
oh my god that killed that one grenade
killed him are shields lowered don't
know
yeah
i feel like they are they definitely are
oh i just got killed nice out of base
no uh jointed guy oh i see him damn it
he's on the left by himself he's right
near the flag he's next to the flag
oh go capture the flag now jointed
dude's not looking ah that's risky
oh there he is yes
pinched him
alright one more round we win
no sorry oh [ __ ] we're blue damn it i
didn't know they were winning
i have one kill guys all right let's do
it
you have one kill yeah i'm holding this
back dude yeah so it's best five out of
nine great uh one guy in the middle
thanks
two guys left
and i'm going left i'm gonna see if i
can get him with the grenade all right
off the bat nope i missed
i'm with your attack [ __ ] there right
near the flag
watch up
they're gonna flank you uh mike yes he's
coming from behind you play what oh i
didn't [ __ ]
damn it
i got one up top oh behind behind rob
[ __ ]
nice you got him yeah tay covered you
there
cause he's my boy ah damn right right
back
yeah he's not right yeah over there over
there
he's he's there he's still there
i think he dropped down
yeah i would dude i'd just camp out
under the flag yeah he's gonna have you
i want you to kill him oh there's two of
them he dropped it
oh he's just now this one
there's one yeah under mine
oh [ __ ] dude he's just kind of is he
trying to throw it at the no you have to
have control of it
[ __ ] you're good
oh that was you almost that was like one
more shot
i think he tried sliding instead
crouched i don't think he had enough
speed so he just it looked like he
crouched on accident um all right
i've not been having great luck
but
one guy is pushing mid got one
oh left oh [ __ ] at the war does he have
the hydra yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] he's just
raining down oh [ __ ] all right all
right you're good you're good
they're both there they're both there
nice holy oh there's a double kill with
the ground uh what do we got here
who's down is he left
no he dropped uh he dropped i see him
i see him [ __ ] terrible aim he's
stuck he's stuck in the counter yeah he
didn't know where to go yeah he was
kinda good job cleaning up nice job
that was terrible lame
went from hero to zero oh who's that in
front
dude
who is it not me oh it was me but rob
has the 2k i got a two candy
it's uh six most kills
you did eight and four
i went four and five that's all right
respectable
i clutched one round that's all divided
by four is two
yeah pretty sure pretty sure
all right so i think that's that for the
stream it was a nice multiplayer session
that's the stream
it's been real fun
um
yeah so uh halo five we did warzone we
did some arena
got a nice versatile uh multiplayer
experience here
uh it's been great so next week
halo 5 comes out on tuesday the 27th
yeah so
we're gonna have something up kind of
like a review in progress kind of just
uh okay
thoughts about the campaign monday
morning at midnight and then um tuesday
hopefully at the earliest we're gonna
have just the full review the score and
everything uh multiplayer thoughts we're
just to make sure the servers are stable
on
monday we don't or tuesday we don't want
to really score anything until make sure
people can play the game unlike master
chief unlike the yeah collection we uh
yeah we're going to make sure that we
have a great
full experience
play
yeah yeah uh but that's the stream
thanks so much for watching so yeah
monday we'll have a bunch of content
going up
on gamespot.com you can count on you
know like a you know war zone piece
we're gonna have some co-op pieces we
played a little bit co-op yeah we'll
play some more of that um
we'll have a few like guides going up
too for just what's new in halo 5 kind
of a roundup and how the requisition
system works because it's a little
confusing at first i'm still a little
confused by it yeah um but i enjoy it i
enjoy it i have some stuff to help
everyone out watch the stream cool
awesome thanks guys nice job later take
care have a great weekend
you